Jesus of course is a central figure of
Christianity since he's viewed as Divine
however although not seen in the exact
same light as the Christian view Jesus
is still a very important figure in the
Islamic faith welcome back to another
episode of FTD facts my name is Leroy
Kenton and in this episode I'm bringing
you 10 surprising and interesting facts
about Jesus inside of the religion of
Islam starting off at number 10. so as
you look throughout the Quran Jesus is
identified as a prophet of God and he
was sent to the Jews who had over time
believed to have deviated from the
teachings of Moses as well as other
prophets there's a time also when Jesus
said children of Israel I am the
Messenger of God sent to you confirming
the Torah which came before and that's
in the Quran Surah 61 verse 6. Jesus is
believed to be the last in line of the
Jewish prophets and he lived according
to the Torah which is a law of Moses as
well as he taught his followers to do
the same also the next thing to note is
that the prophet Muhammad is is only
mentioned a total of four times in the
Quran while Jesus whoever is mentioned
25 times by name not a lot of people
know that now while Jesus is reckon I
didn't know that as this I thought like
the whole book was out was about him how
does that even make any sense Muhammad
yeah it was by Muhammad it was about God
but he only mentioned himself he was the
prophet who got all the messages from
God and wrote it all down you're right
you're right I should have known so
where the the New Testament none of it
was written by Jesus it was all written
by other people so that's why it's all
Jesus all the time because they're
talking about someone else that makes a
lot more sense
now while Jesus is recognized as the Son
of God in the Bible the Quran however
uses other titles for Jesus but it
doesn't use the term Son of God it uses
titles like the messenger of God the
word of God Son of Mary even at one
point it uses the term the spirit from
God now on top of that Jesus is referred
more than any other person in the Quran
next to Moses but not all mentions are
by name instead some of these references
just use a term like Messiah and Son of
Mary and things like that another
popular Muslim I I didn't even this is
all just weird to me because I didn't
even know the Quran was a book until
like six months ago and I didn't hearing
about it I never would have thought
Jesus would have been inside of it I
would have always just thought it's like
this completely random new religion yeah
there was only one small step ahead of
you and knowing that the Quran existed
and but I absolutely did not know and
and the only thing I'd heard through the
years is what the news media will feed
us at you know especially after uh
September 2001 is you know all the all
the horror horrible stuff you know or
the Twisted how how a certain very small
sect of terrorists who happen to be
Muslim also how they Twisted the Quran
you know that those are the only things
we ever heard out of the Quran at all
literally when I would think Muslim I
think like it's it's bad but this is
what it's like shown it's I think like
Iran women can't do anything bombs
that's like that's just like what I
would like isn't that crazy though it's
sad no but it's really I'm just no no
I'm not a no no judgment on you it's
just sad that it's another example of
what we talk about all the time how the
media just fills our head with bullshits
that isn't true they make why they would
want to do that again maybe it's just
another way to keep us divided just one
more way get us to make sure that we
never we never become friends with the
Muslims in this country let's keep them
outside because if we become friends
with them we might actually realize we
have a lot in common and we might be
able to you know get together and be a
force for good it's crazy but instead it
it's better that we just hate each other
oh my God it's but you're so right those
things now I I don't think all those
things you know what did you say bombs
and like women women so when I think
about because that's what it's like this
but I think see I don't think when I
hear when I think of that I think of the
Taliban like they've been really bad but
they're a political group but I feel
like the way the media has it they've
just like mixed those two together
absolutely that's right when they say
Taliban they always say Muslim Muslim
Muslim so they make it seem bad and
they've done that to Christians in in
this country in in recent years I mean
you can really look in the news and
there's just [ __ ] on Christians
constant and you know again it's just
another way to keep us divided and to if
you demonize groups of people they
become scariest now the Muslims are
scary to the Liberals the Christians are
scary is uh follow the liberal ideology
and that's like a whole religion in
itself is following that that's that's
the craziest of all the religions right
don't follow any of this stuff that
people have been following for thousands
of years to be happy follow us I okay
real quick so you know I go on Twitter
just started Twitter recently and I'll
make one comment and oh my God I'm more
conservative right so the Liberals just
come after me I mean name calling me uh
what was I was called Trailer Trash
stupid this is just in the last 24 hours
something maybe you know shouldn't have
been born like just just mean [ __ ] that
people are saying and so since we
started doing these videos and
particularly these just to talk about
Islam I have gotten such lovely messages
everybody on here I'm over here and I'm
butchering it I'm butchering the whole
thing I'm asking questions I don't know
anything about this religion I know more
than I did a week ago okay but none of
them are coming at me going you ignorant
no exactly broad go educate yourself
they're all saying I'm getting all these
messages and thousands of comments
saying thank you for having this
conversation and being kind about it
like how bad have they been treated by
Americans that they have to even say
thank you for just being decent like I'm
embarrassed and I'm sad bad about it
yeah that's crazy these people are so
freaking nice to me and my own American
white you know I don't know
judeo-christian countrymen are calling
me the most horrible names because I
disagree with them on something and it's
wild and like I'm here legit saying the
truth like like not the like I'm here
saying what I what I've honestly thought
for a while and then I get thousands of
DMs like if you have any questions
brother feel free to reach out it's
crazy it's just like I've never seen
anything like it in my life so it's
pretty cool you ignorant [ __ ] that's
what they say the Americans it's
terrible but they like I think they're
smarter because like they recognize why
I think that you know what I mean so
like me saying the truth it's like yeah
that makes sense you think that because
it's like what the media portrays all
right let's keep going yeah it's kind of
it's kind of it's kind of nice huh oh
yeah view is that out of all the
prophets and messengers of God Jesus is
the only messenger who received the
title of Messiah and that's also found
in the Quran now the term can be
translated as the anointed one and the
phrase in Arabic C also refers to the
role of Jesus in the end times in Islam
but most of the information about
Jesus's role in the end times is found
in the Hadith which are the records of
Islamic traditions and sayings of the
Prophet Muhammad and not actually in the
Quran itself now the next thing to note
is that not quit Christian there's other
writings that are not in the that
Muhammad wrote that are not the Quran is
that what he just said because this guy
is just educating us really fast I feel
like I'm in like I'm not in Islam 101
anymore Islam 102. I think that's what
he said yeah not just Christians believe
that Jesus was born of a virgin so when
you go back to the birth of Jesus
Muslims believe that Jesus was born of
the Virgin Mary in a miraculous birth
which was a miracle by God there's also
interesting to note that inside of the
Quran Jesus actually talks while he's in
a cradle like as a baby it says this
then she Mary pointed to him and they
said how can we talk to one who is a
child in the Cradle he Jesus said verily
I am a slave of God he has given me the
scriptures and made me a prophet and
that's in Quran baby said that that's
okay so this is a whole new a whole new
thing that I've never heard before did
you know that baby Jesus could talk in
the Cradle no like I didn't know that I
mean you could walk on water and [ __ ] so
that's not the craziest thing I've heard
no and I believe all the things I
believe that she was a virgin I've been
and I believe that um her cousin
Elizabeth had gave birth to John the
Baptist she was very old in her 80s or
90s when she did that I believe in all
of the Miracles and all of his power and
so how do you differentiate now I have
to wrap my head around talking baby I'm
sorry that's how do you differentiate
what's known as like what is it myth
where it's like the Adam and Eve story
and stuff like that and what's like
actual facts to not be interpreted this
is a question for a far more advanced
theologian
or a theologian at all but there is
there there has to be some Faith
involved in all of this but because it
just sounds like it like I don't know
like that just sounds crazy but I mean I
guess there's been craziest crazier [ __ ]
that happens but like does he have like
a baby voice I want to watch again I'm
gonna bring up the movie the case for
Christ and I actually think you and I
should just sit down and watch it and
get it over with so that you can
understand my thinking on how this me
how Lee Strobel went out of his way to
prove that God didn't exist and ended up
finding him and a lot of it was because
of tremend more eyewitness accounts and
more physical physical data more um
medical understanding things that happen
during Jesus's life that could not that
prove that it could not have been a
forest that the resurrection was real uh
so I think that you have to really dig
and do the research and then that other
video we we watched where we were like
watching all the things that Muhammad
said that had tremendous scientific
knowledge that didn't come out for
thousands of years later you know yeah
so so there there's actual how do you
dispute that everything he said is a
coincidence you know so or or is there
really God involved I don't know if that
answers your question but I feel like
yeah if I understood your question
correctly 29 to 30. now I don't know
about you guys about profit or not sign
from God or not Miracle or not I don't
care if I see a talking baby
it's a wrap like I'm gone guys also
Jesus is known for performing many
miracles you're gonna go tell everyone
who you ever met and that's probably
what happened like did you talk to the
wise man when they came to bring the
presents and it was like oh you didn't
have to bring frankincense it was so
nice of you the Quran says in Surah 5
verses 110 behold I taught you the book
and wisdom the law and the gospel and
behold you make out of clay as it were
the figure of a bird by my leave and you
breathe into it and it becomes a bird by
my leave and you heal those born blind
and the lepers by my leave and behold
you bring forth the dead by my leave so
those are multiple Miracles that Jesus
was able to perform according to the
Quran now let's talk about Jesus in the
end times according to popular Muslim
belief so in the end times Jesus is
actually going to declare Islam to be
the True Religion and all of the
Christians will convert at the time so
all other religions will be eliminated
but the Earth is going to experience
peas like even the animal kingdom is
going to experience peace crops and
Wildlife and everything is just going to
be super flourishing and for this time
period there's going to be no Wars it's
just going to be complete peace however
this reign of Jesus is believed to just
last only 40 years and during that time
he'll go to Mecca regularly to perform
uh the pilgrimage it's also believed
that he's gonna have children and then
eventually pass away and buried in
Medina next to the prophet Muhammad now
again that's not the blanket belief of
the Muslims it's just based on a popular
school of thought all right two more
facts left the prophet Muhammad is often
seen by non-muslims as the equivalent to
Jesus when you compare it to
Christianity however according to the
Quran Muslims believe that Jesus is not
greater or better than the prophet
Muhammad and also the other Prophet
Muhammad isn't greater or better than
Jesus as a matter of fact no Prophet is
greater than any other Prophet they're
just prophets that God sent to fulfill a
certain purpose and that's pretty much
it and the final thing is when we look
just like God's Little minions yeah no
profit is greater than any other profit
so there are plenty of profits that just
didn't make a big splash I mean Jesus
Moses those are biggies Muhammad biggie
maybe in the eyes of God it's different
John the Baptist was a big big one but
not not nearly as big as Jesus
crucifixion of Jesus Muslims believe
according to the Quran that Jesus was
not crucified rather it appeared that he
was crucified and that instead of being
buried he was actually taken up from the
cross and God brought him to heaven now
the Quran doesn't necessarily explain
who that person was that was actually
crucified that looked like Jesus they
believed that it appeared to be Jesus
but there's no real detail about who
that other person was you can find this
in the Quran in Surah 4 verses 157 it
said they did not kill him nor did they
crucify him but another was made to
resemble him to them and also it says in
Surah 4 verses 158 God lifted him up to
his presence God is Almighty all wise
all right guys
us or Barnabas and he was there at
Jesus's crucifixion and they were some
group of people I'm butchering this
we're trying to get him to like let the
Romans like take take him and spare
Jesus and they they didn't so maybe
that's what happened is what they're
saying but again there was there was
tremendous evidence that it was Jesus do
you think if I read the Quran it'll be
like reading Shakespeare where I'm just
like I have no idea what's going on who
do you think I'll actually because even
reading the Bible I'm like I'm just lost
that's why that's why I just made that
big sigh because I I love understanding
the Bible and I love hearing the verses
as explained by a really you know a
vibrant Pastor or you know a show like
The Chosen where they're really playing
it out but just reading it is is
excruciating I can't I've tried several
times in my life so I don't know if the
Quran is as uh heavy duty as that it's
never changed like the Quran has
literally never changed and it's been
the same language forever so you think
it would be it would be easier
but that's what makes it harder I mean I
don't think whatever Bible I've ever
picked up even the Bibles were dummies
2022 yeah updated Jesus Bible the urban
dictionary Bible which actually somebody
should write because maybe that would
help so don't don't kill babies be a
good person don't go burning down stores
like oh it all makes sense now
cool that last part I'm not driving with
that he wasn't really resurrected that
he wasn't really the one killed but um
as always I I would of course be happy
to be I'd love to hear a Muslim scholar
and a Christian scholar I'd love to hear
them have that conversation and put all
the information on the table and then
perhaps politely debate it so
fascinating all right thank you for
watching make sure to hit the Subscribe
button to keep watching more there's a
lot more of these types of videos coming
so make sure you follow along and follow
us on Instagram I just want to say
thanks to everybody that is watching for
sending you know just sending so much
love and and also sending me I've been
watching been getting some YouTube links
from people saying look at this a
thousand years and I know but I'm trying
to watch I'm trying to watch watch them
you know and learn as I go so I I do
appreciate them and I am reading them
and trying to click them even if you
can't respond to everything because you
guys are being amazing
[Music]
yeah the feelings
[Music]